so we get to talk all things valentine's
day and it's less than a week away and
if you're still looking for plans we
have you covered you can celebrate the
day of love with an intimate dining
experience at the four seasons and here
to tell us more about it is ross zega
the mixologist at press ross thank you
so much for being here pleasure to be
here so i'm really excited about this i
see champagne i see pink i see flowers
lots of fun stuff before we start making
the drink just tell us a little bit
about what's going on at the fourth
season so for valentine's day our chefs
came up with a five course fix uh fix
dinner for couples that starts at five
o'clock wow so i'm sure it's gonna be
some delicious food and some fun drinks
to go along with it so okay you don't
want me to make the drink i'm gonna
switch spots with you ross you're gonna
come over here tell me about this
cocktail and i love the name of it
what's the name so it's called 50 shades
of pink so cute this is fun
this was a cocktail that was inspired
for valentine's day we're going to be
doing this all february as our feature
cocktail for the month
and what it is we wanted to take
everything for valentine's day and put
it into one glass i love it all right
let's get started what is this this is
stoli elite this is stoli's premium
ultra vodka all right i like that bottle
yeah okay so an an ounce or two of that
half of that okay this is saint germain
which is a french elderflower okay
elderberry look here excuse me sounds
fancy i like it we're going to add a
half ounce of that right into the shaker
okay
all right then this is some fresh
watermelon juice that we make in house
so that gives it that pink color i'm
getting that pink color and a little bit
of fruit flavor and freshness a little
bit of sweet i'm liking this all right
next up this is fresh squeezed lemon
juice okay that kind of adds a little
bit a little bit little citrus and it
kind of balances out the cocktail all
right perfect and then this is a little
dab of our house made simple syrup
okay i like sweet stuff so i'm really
excited about this now this is the best
part this is rose water this is the
secret ingredient
what does that add to the drink so what
this does it
adds this beautiful fragrance where as
you're drinking it it feels like if
you're tasting a fresh fresh dozen of
roses oh my god perfect for valentine's
day this is so fun okay so then that
goes all in the shaker okay
shake it up
see this is why i'm glad you're the one
doing it
and i love these glasses that we have
here so you're going to pour that in
here absolutely so you got to get it
just right
so then that gets strained into our
cocktail glass okay over crushed ice
let's see
look at that is it that nice beautiful
pinkish color love it it matches the
flowers
and um let me guess are we topping it
off yes absolutely okay so valentine's
day is not right without some champagne
so this is one of our favorites this is
valve wow that goes right over the top
my favorite sound
bubbles this is our version of our
valentine's day champagne cocktail this
is great and then we're garnishing it
with some fresh rose bottles wow that
was right on the top
okay the more pink the better this is
great okay can i try it please let me me
know it's 50 shades of pink right yes
okay i'm one on earth look at how pretty
this is ross thank you so much and as
i'm taking a step just let people know
you know where they can find you and if
the reservations are still open for them
yeah so reservations can be made by
calling the four seasons directly at 702
702-632-5000
thank you so much and it smells really
good too as you take a sip you can sell
the flowers
it's all aroma well i love it ross thank
you so much cheers to valentine's day
i'm just going to be sipping on this the
rest of the day
all right coming up get swole with your
sweetheart